equipment on the front line of the
ukrainian war drones medical kits even
mine detectors all provided by
crowdfunding
a charity in ukraine set up after the
russian invasion of crimea in 2014 has
raised millions of dollars
it's the founder a former high profile
presenter on ukrainian tv it's very good
that we have uh
so some big connection between society
and the army
because it's really important for our
soldiers that we carry about them
they understand that they're not alone
and that it's not only a
military
case to defend our country the idea of
crowdfunding like this isn't new it's
been around since before the first world
war what is different is the technology
with cryptocurrency and cash transfers
money can be in accounts within seconds
from anywhere in the world
frontline units fill in what they need
online the order is processed and sent
more than a million donations have come
in from all around the world more than
34 million dollars ranging from big cash
drops from wealthy individuals to
pennies from pensioners
nine-year-old tanya portachenko played
checkers on the street losers had to pay
her she raised six thousand ukrainian
rivena about 200 dollars
[Music]
i was doing this in order to give to the
armed forces of ukraine so they will
fight against the russians so they kick
them off our land
the charity now has about 200 volunteers
around the country experts in purchasing
logistics technology the ultimate goal
to beat the russians but the russians
have been crowdfunding too figures
suggest they've not been quite as
successful but the ukrainian group's
founder says even when the war is done
his work will continue we fight with
russians 900 years
and
the biggest idea
that i have now uh is just to help
ukrainian army to win and after that
to
start to prepare for the next attack
the ukrainians believe they can get most
equipment to the front line in a couple
of days easy
as long as the money continues to flow
alan fisher al jazeera keeve